Speaker 1: The other thing Kevin McCarthy
did today was not just involving going to
the White House and not speaking in complete
sentences that can be understood by people who
their native tongue is English. He was a prayer
breakfast. The the the the the gathering for
prayer and repentance. A Tony Perkins joint, I
guess. And it is a gathering of of of Christian
nationalists and radicals. And there were over
a dozen members of Congress there today. And
I'm going to play I'm going to play a couple
of clips here. One, Kevin McCarthy went and
actually gave a prayer at this thing with members
of Congress, Republicans in Congress before him
doing his father God thing. And and we're really
laying it on thick that he's some holy, devout,
righteous man of God. And give you a flavor
for that. Then let's move on to Andrew Brunson,
who is a Christian nationalist preacher who is
just laying the bigotry, just wrapping it up to
11. Watch Kevin McCarthy. Give us a little prayer.
Speaker 2: Dear Heavenly Father,
we come before you today to seek your forgiveness.
Father, we thank you for that forgiveness. We
thank you for your love. We thank you for your
grace. Father, I want to lift up these faith
leaders from across the nation. Father, I want to
thank you that we can pray and seek your word and
seek your forgiveness in the Museum of the Bible.
Speaker 1: It's all a bit much. Look, this is not
intended as as a mockery of religion. This is
my faith tradition. This is what I grew up in.
Is this this this flavor of of evangelicalism.
Ultimately, what is white Christian nationalism?
But to parade yourself out, praying
to Jesus Christ while jettisoning any
adherence to the philosophies of the actual
man is just. I mean, blasphemy comes to mind.
Sharing the stage with a woman off to the
left there on your screen. Mary Miller
is someone who has praised Hitler in speeches
right outside the United States Capitol.
But let's go to Andrew Brunson.
Who is giving a. Just a wild,
bigoted screed talking about us living
under a mean ruled by the rainbow flag.
It's. Well, let's talk about it
on the other side. Watch this.
Speaker 2: I believe that we are in danger
of judgment as a nation, especially because
we have become the primary character of the
world, and particularly of youth and children.
Our government and corporations
increasingly march under the rainbow flag.
Speaker 1: We bully weaker and poorer countries.
Speaker 2: To come under that flag. Our
universities train millions of foreign students
who return to their countries with this ideology.
Our social media and entertainment companies
make it attractive. They promote. They normalize,
celebrate immorality, and there is no
escaping them. As a blanket the world.
There are godly mothers and fathers around the
world who fear our influence. Sometimes when
I'm in a foreign country, I want to fall on my
knees and repent for what we are doing to these
countries, to these people. Jesus said, Woe to
the ones to the one who causes others to send.
And he underlines this, especially in relation
to the young. Whoever causes one of these little
ones to send. It would be better for him
if a millstone were hung around his neck
and he were drowned in the depths of the sea.
Speaker 1: I hate to break it to you, Andrew
Brunson. Gay people exist. And we're not marching.
Our government and corporations increasingly march
under the rainbow flag. Gay people exist. And
they are American citizens who have rights.
Equal protection. As far as the 14th Amendment of
the Constitution. And for Kevin McCarthy to share
the same stage on the same day within a frame
of a few minutes as this bigot is alarming.
This is the political battle of the
next 8 to 10 years, maybe beyond.
Because they're no longer quiet, they're no longer
whispering about being Christian nationalists.
And again, when you hear Christian nationalist,
you should automatically know that it is white
Christian nationalist, because these same people
who talk about the philosophies of Jesus, they
don't want equality for everyone. They don't want
equity on a stage through education or financial
assistance in this country. They
want to prop up white supremacy.
They want to oppress gay people. They want
to strip away women's reproductive rights.
And if if you don't think that it's important and
you think that I'm just rambling here about some
prayer breakfast. You need to pay a closer
cultural attention to what is taking place,
because this has been a concerted effort, a
strategic effort over the course of decades when
the religious right and the the Moral Majority of
Jerry Falwell, this is what they've led to. This
is what they have planned and strategically worked
for over the course of 30 or 40 or 50 years.
And they're getting their way. They're
winning. Roe v Wade was overturned.
By a group of fanatical religious nut
bags who sit on the Supreme Court.
And it would be one thing if it was just Andrew
Brunson, some guy you've probably never heard of.
But it's not just Andrew Brunson.
Randy Weber, Republican from Texas, actually
gave a prayer here. I'm going to play it for you
where he's sobbing and weeping about all
the millions of babies that we've killed.
He's he's begging God for forgiveness to put
America back on the right path to worshiping
you. We've taken God out of the classroom.
Ignoring. The First Amendment of the Constitution.
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion. But they want
Jesus in the classroom. Talk to little Muslim
kids or little Jewish kids or little atheist kids.
So it's not just Andrew Brunson. It is
members of Congress who have the power
to vote on legislation. Who are there to. Who
are who are luxuriating in the bigotry. Watch.
Speaker 4: Randy Weber Father, you say in your
world that unless the Lord watches over the city,
the watchmen stay awake in vain. Lord, we
are a nation without a rudder adrift. Father,
We think we're so smart. We've kicked you out of
schools, we've kicked prayer out, we've kicked
the Ten Commandments, and we've replaced you with
drug sniffing dogs, with armed police officers,
with metal detectors. Lord forgive us, Father.
We've trampled on holy matrimony. Lord God,
we have killed so many babies, and we call them
a choice. And I remember and did wrong me. 3019
Moses called Israel to choose life so that we
and all of our descendants could live. Lord,
our descendants aren't living. We're killing them
in the world. Father, you also say in your word
that tomorrow is slave to the lender. And Lord,
we have totally forgotten your words and your
precepts. And we're $33 trillion in debt. Father,
we think we're so smart. But, Lord, please forgive
us. Please, please put America back on the right
path to worshiping you. Father, I ask this through
the blood of the lamb. Jesus Christ. Amen.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Come on, man. That guy gets to vote on
legislation. That guy has an impact on
your everyday life. Sobbing and
wailing and gnashing of teeth.
Weeping that he cannot rule your
life with his Christo fascism.
That we've trampled on holy matrimony
because dudes can get married now. What?
It's all. It's all. Dangerous. That will
impact your life at some point. You might
not feel it now, but in eight or ten years, if
this is ignored, we're going to be in a really
tough spot. Once again, I am Jesse Dallimore.
I'd love to see you follow me on social media
at Dallimore on Twitter, Instagram. Tik Tok just
at dallimore. Look for me here on YouTube. Just
search my name Dallimore Daily. I host just
about every day and I host a twice weekly
podcast called I Doubt It that you can find
anywhere that you find podcasts. See you there.